let's talk about this guy named joe
biden okay let's talk about what he's
got going on
[Laughter]
okay so uh joe biden proposes largest
tax increase since lbj political insider
biden's 2023 fiscal budget reposes that
all the bad ideas that congress won't
pass and has a new twist the coveted
liberal well tax bidens wishlist costs
for increasing the top marginal tax rate
to 39.6 from 37 it would also uh nearly
double on capital gains to 39.6 for
people earning over a million dollars
this would be the highest tax rate on
investment gains since 1920s this tax
unrealized gains which are not taxed
until assets are converted to income
liquid since liquid assets make up less
than 20 the wealth investors will have
to incentivize
to hold liquid assets such as real
estate to avoid liquidating stocks to
pay taxes rather than sell stocks to
diversify to reinvest investors will be
forced to sell stocks to pay taxes on
realized capital gains do you think
there is a chance that any of this
stuff's going to pass through or do you
think a guy named joe manchin is going
to say listen have i not already made it
clear i'm not supporting a massive tax
increase what do you think is going to
happen here i think you're right i don't
think anything is going to really get
passed uh it may be a baby step maybe a
part of that uh
proposal gets gets through
that everyone can agree upon is a
reasonable tax but that at least we're
talking about politics now what we
should be talking about tax rates what
is a fair tax rate what is an unfair tax
rate what is an unfair loophole for the
wealthy what is you know
a bad policy you always talk about
democrats having terrible fiscal policy
what are the good policies where do you
draw the line when you talk about taxes
being a a punishment or a reward for
being a member of a society where you
can become wealthy what is that line and
that's what the debate is and it shifts
depending on the economic state of the
country does it let me ask you so how
hard do you think it is to start a
business and make it succeed how hard do
you think it is i know how hard it is
okay how hard do you think it is it's
really hard so unpack that like how hard
is really hard like
what a lifetime of commitment
does it affect your personal life in
every way do you miss some birthdays do
you miss practices do you miss dinners
do you miss
how many people are willing to go
through that okay so now let's go
another side what else
a job or occupation is harder than being
a business owner
that requires a lot of risk
and requires
you
having to
do work that you're not going to get
paid
maybe any money for a while what's
harder job than that
professional athlete
i think professional that's just random
that's it but i think that's a game
though i think that's genetics a part of
it is genetics a part of it is i can't
jump 46 inches right
so i think that is the luck of the draw
like shannon sharp says listen man i
understand i was born like this
there's nothing you can do to be as
athletic as i am right you've seen
shannon sharp yeah guys a monster right
what do you think's as hard
as that i struggle to answer that
question because i think every endeavor
is a business in right
unless you're an artist but you're still
trying to sell your you still gotta eat
yeah but but but the risk of starting a
business putting your all your money in
it
it is so challenging
so hollywood let's go to hollywood it is
so hard to make it in hollywood how hard
is it it's easier to get struck by
lightning twice in your life than to be
successful working okay so look what you
just said right there but i'm okay
really so yeah so let me ask let me ask
you a question you think uh steph curry
you know do we have a stephen curry
without a dell curry
no no we don't have a stephen curry
without adelker do we have a peyton
manning or eli manning without archie
manning no sir do we have a tiger woods
without his father no do we have a the
williams sisters without the father
richard no we don't have it right okay
so that's luck of the draw right who
your father is there's a lot of incense
and benefits that you have with that
but
some of these guys that work their asses
off to get there man if a guy gets paid
a lot of money and you have to do a lot
of sacrifice and work to get there i
support that cause from to make that
money you have to create incentive for
whatever is very very hard or else
people are just not going to do it
that's the basic premise for me with
taxes right i get that whatever's very
hard i want to create that incentive
bigger for you so now
as a government when it comes down to
taxes so you're you're a parent you have
kids
you're
a parent you have two kittens i'm a
parent i have four kids right as a
parent who has kids you know
you
as a as a parent sit there and say that
guy took that pressure off my plate wow
pretty impressive so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]